So the second grade on truth always
trust your feelings.
The wisdom traditions of the entire
world say don't do that.
For example,
some of the quotes we have in the book,
uh,
from Shakespeare,
there's nothing good or bad,
but thinking makes it so from Marcus
Aurelius,
the whole world has changed and life
itself is,
but what you deem it,
uh,
from Buddha,
our thoughts are the creations of our
minds.
With our minds.
We make the world.
CBT is just a way of teaching people
skills to do exactly that,
to question their feelings,
to look for evidence.
Uh,
so in CBT you learn the names of these
distortions,
about 15 or so distortions.
You can guess what they mean.
Catastrophizing,
black and white thinking,
labeling,
mind reading.
These are the things that depressed and
anxious people do a lot.
One way to sort of keep all of us have
had experiences of these.
One thing I like to think about as homer
Simpson saying,
shut up brain or I'll stab you with a
qtip.
Our brains do this.
Our brains go on and on.
But like stop it,
stop it,
stop it.
Well,
CBT is a way of stopping it.
It's so easy to learn.
Many people,
including me,
learned it from a wonderful book by
David Burns called feeling good.
Um,
in our book,
we and on our webpage,
if you go to the coddling.org,
uh,
we have suggestions for books and apps
where you can learn it.
Cognitive behavioral therapy is not more
effective than several other treatments.
There are.
Most treatments are about equally
effective,
but it's so easy to learn if you teach,
and I've done this in my classes,
if you assign everyone in the class to
learn CBT,
most people get it and get something out
of it.
Other techniques like meditation work,
but they're harder.
Most people drop off.
So cbt is easy,
really well tested,
has a huge impact on a variety of mental
health and mental illnesses,
especially those related to depression
and anxiety.
We think every college student and heck,
every high school student should be
taught these basic skills given how high
the rates of anxiety and depression are
today.
So for the last few years we've been
hearing reports that counseling centers
on campus or overwhelmed.
We're hearing stories about rising
depression and anxiety.
Some people say,
oh,
it's nothing to be alarmed about.
It's not real.
It's just that young people today,
they're so comfortable talking about
mental illness,
they're more open about it,
and that's why the rates seem to be
rising.
Sounds plausible.
Not True.
It's not just that young people are more
comfortable.
We know this because studies have been
done looking at hospital admission data
who is being admitted to hospitals
because they cut themselves,
they took poison,
they harmed themselves in some other
way.
We see exactly the same curves,
uh,
on that date in particular,
boys are not changing,
but girls are going way,
way up.
Only teenage girls,
not millennials,
not kids born before 1995 but kids born
in 1995 and after the girls in
particular are cutting themselves and
being admitted to hospitals and much
higher rates.
Most alarmingly,
the suicide rate,
if you look at the last couple of years,
compared to the first 10 years of the
century,
the suicide rate for American boys,
teenage boys is up 25%,
which is a gigantic increase.
The suicide rate for American girls is
up to 70%.
So something is going wrong.
Something is affecting American
teenagers,
especially girls.
Uh,
so in the United States right now is
many people have noticed,
uh,
we are,
we are seeing a huge escalation of our
long running culture war.
Unfortunately,
universities are right in the heart of
that.
The right loves to come in and say,
Hey,
the university is our bastions of
political correctness.
They've lost their minds.
The left is motivated to say,
no,
there's no not a problem.
There's nothing going on.
It's just that the right hates ideas.
They hate universities.
So the way that this whole book started
is that Greg Lukey on,
off my coauthor and friend,
um,
is prone to depression and he had a
suicidal depression in 2007.
He was hospitalized and he learned
cognitive behavioral therapy as part of
his treatment and he credits it with
saving his life.
Um,
so he goes back to his job as the
president of the foundation for
individual rights and education.
He's been fighting for free speech
rights for students,
pushing back against administrators who
are always imposing speech limits.
Students were always his best
supporters.
Students generally wanted the rights to
speak and think and,
and,
and be independent.
Until 2013 beginning of the fall of 2013
he started seeing the first cases of
students saying,
we want protections from words,
books,
ideas,
speakers.
We want speakers.
Disinvited don't let this person onto
our campus.
Not because it will be offensive,
but because it will be dangerous.
It will be harmful.
It will be traumatizing.
We want trigger warnings if you're going
to assign a book that has violence in
it,
especially sexual violence,
like a Greek myth,
which has rape,
if you're going to sign that,
you need to warn students against it.
Um,
so that they can choose whether they
want to absent themselves on that day.
So this was something new.
And at first it was just a strange thing
at a few schools.
And then over the following year,
it built to the point where in 2014 we
started reading articles in the new
republic and the New York Times about
trigger warnings,
safe spaces,
microaggression,
training,
bias response teams.
A whole set of constructs and procedures
emerged on certain universities,
not everywhere,
but especially at elite schools in the
northeast and on the west coast.
A way of protecting students from words,
books,
ideas,
and speakers.
Speakers were shouted down increasingly
not because they were offensive and
hateful because they were dangerous.
For students to think about ideas in
terms of right or wrong is great,
exciting versus boring is great,
but safe versus dangerous.
This is a terrible way to approach the
world.
So,
uh,
Greg came to talk to me because what he
saw with students doing the exact
cognitive distortions that he had
learned to stop doing when he was
treated for cognitive behavioral therapy
when he's treated for depression,
greg was concerned that if students are
beginning to think this way about safety
and danger and harmfulness,
that this is gonna make them depressed
and anxious.
And that's what led us to write our
original article in the,
in the Atlantic in 2015 titled the
coddling of the American mind.
Um,
we published the article in 2015 before
a big wave of student protests in around
Halloween of 2015.
So these,
these trends that we saw that greg and I
both saw hints of in 2014,
they exploded in the fall of 2015.
Uh,
they've spread much more widely in the
couple of years since then.
And at the same time we're seeing rates
of depression and anxiety increasing
rapidly too.
We're not saying these are causing that,
we don't know,
but there is a national wave of
depression.
Students are thinking in terms of safety
and danger.
Students say by their own admission they
are more fragile.
They use a language of fragility,
weakness,
trauma triggering.
They see triggers all over the world.
What are triggers?
Triggers are cases where you take a part
of your nervous system and you say,
if someone says that word,
they can control my nervous system and
make me afraid and anxious.
That's a terrible idea.
We should not be teaching our kids to,
to see the world as being full of
triggers.
We should teach them to live in a world
that is physically quite safe,
but full of offensive statements and
ideas,
especially on the Internet.
A sad commentary on the state of a,
of the business world now is that Google
is being sued from both sides,
from women who say that they're a
victims of a hostile climate and from
conservatives and white men who say that
conserves and white men are
discriminated against.
So in our current era,
everybody feels they're a victim.
Um,
the truth is that diversity of
perspectives is essential for healthy
organizations,
especially those who care about
innovation.
We have to address all of the diversity
issues.
At the same time.
We can't pit them against each other.
We have to work on our speech climate,
uh,
in the business world is called speak up
culture.
Uh,
in the academic world,
it's called just basic openness to
ideas.
We're having problems all across
American society.
We've got to work on them.